a una pequeña isla tailandesa que se
está convirtiendo en un centro mundial
para nómadas digitales desde espacios de
trabajo compartido hasta palmeras
cientos de adultos jóvenes han
convertido esta joya en su oficina
temporal go bank and se ha convertido en
un paraíso tropical para
teletrabajadores durante la pandemia
esta escasa tropicana uno de los
principales lugares de trabajo
compartido de la isla
aquí las personas trabajan en
informática monedas digitales y
desarrollo de páginas web
lorin 1 una mujer de 43 años de parís
estaba viajando por el mundo cuando el
coronavirus detuvo su viaje ahora está
trabajando en el lanzamiento de un
producto para una cadena de sushi en
europa y ganó dos mil euros al mes estoy
trabajando en el empaque estoy creando
todas las cuentas de redes sociales
creando contenido para instagram y
facebook desde aquí
a distancia esa distancia lo estás
disfrutando me encanta en las
instalaciones hay un bar restaurante y
una decena de cuartos pero muchos de
esos nómadas digitales han tomado la
decisión de alquilar una vivienda
privada flor y alquila su cabaña por 280
euros al mes
me duermo con el sonido de las olas los
demás sonidos que escucho son los
pescadores que van y vienen para mí esto
es el paraíso nunca había estado tan
cerca de la naturaleza por tanto tiempo
por lo general en las grandes ciudades
uno solo se toma una semana libre ahora
la naturaleza es mi hogar y realmente lo
necesitaba
otros nómadas digitales han tomado la
decisión de quedarse en un hotel pero se
ha generado una verdadera sensación de
comunidad en la isla
un amigo que conocí aquí creó mi página
web gratis otro amigo que conocí en una
pista de baile creó el logo conocí a un
voluntario que era editor de una revista
de finanzas alemana y corrigió los
artículos que yo estaba escribiendo es
maravilloso
la sensación de comunidad fue lo que
hizo que su feedback se lea se enamorara
de la isla solía hacer consultorías en
parís ahora publica vídeos de yoga en
internet
cuando empezó la pandemia renunció a su
trabajo y a su salario mensual de tres
mil quinientos euros pero cree en la
decisión que tomó todas las semanas cada
mujer recibirá una clase de yoga una
clase de meditación un taller personal
de desarrollo y un aceite esencial y lo
haces desde aquí desde aquí o desde
cualquier parte puede ser desde
cualquier lugar recibirás un pago si las
mujeres compran la guía sí pero
realmente creo que lo harán entonces si
atraer cada vez más nómadas digitales a
esta isla se ha convertido en un trabajo
de tiempo completo para algunos como
para este francés que administra los
espacios de trabajo compartido cree que
la pandemia generará aún más demanda
creo que el gobierno aceleró la
revolución del trabajo remoto unos cinco
o seis años un hecho muy simple es que
hace un año millones de personas nunca
se imaginaron la posibilidad de trabajar
de manera remota
entonces para recibirlos abrió un hotel
45 cuartos
un sauna y un jacuzzi desde 550 euros al
mes
[Música]
y hay personas que trabajan de manera
remota y ganan mucho dinero y todos
estos ejecutivos pronto necesitarán un
lugar para vivir y trabajar hawai
durante la semana estos nómadas
digitales se relajan gracias a las
fiestas
tan pronto como se levanten las
restricciones sufi dice que planea ir a
bali o a sydney
esto me ha enseñado que todo es posible
que uno puede cambiar su vida si quiere
hacerlo tal vez en cinco años decida que
eso no es para mí y regresé a la
consultoría pero por ahora me veo
haciendo esto por muchos años
para atraer cada vez más a estos
trabajadores jóvenes y bien conectados
tailandia está en proceso de crear una
visa especial de trabajo para estos son
nómadas digitales